un score fleuve en faveur de Poissy
après une première mi-temps compliquée
l'épicéa qui ont remporté cette
rencontre 5 buts à deux face à Évreux
pourtant tout avait bien commencé pour
les Normands d'abord sur penalty
[Applaudissements]
puis sur une action collective conclue
par un centre repris face au but
des Yvelines par rapport à leurs
adversaires
à chaque fois on répondait quand même
marqué parce qu'on a pris des buts aussi
sur des erreurs individuelles donc le
fait que nous on arrive à marquer
derrière ça rebooster l'équipe à chaque
fois il manquait juste à monter en
intensité à plus d'applications plus de
courses
et plus de concentration juste un petit
peu plus dans chaque domaine et je pense
que on a mis ça en application ça a été
nettement meilleur au retour des
vestiaires le score de 2 évolue très
rapidement voici accélère après un
premier but en première mi-temps Amadou
Konaté inscrit un doublé
l'attaquant est aussi passeur décisif
l'épicyciaquer retrouve le goût de la
victoire une saveur qui n'avait plus
connu depuis le 4 mars et un succès à
l'extérieur contre Guingamp 2 ils
occupent aujourd'hui la sixième place au
classement à la trêve on est premier et
là on était toujours pas maintenus donc
voilà c'est mes l'essentiel c'est ça
c'est que on a fait là on a aujourd'hui
on a réussi à prendre les points ça
faisait longtemps ça nous fait du bien
et il reste trois matchs il faudra bien
les négocier déjà il nous manque 7
points en classement par cette perte
bête donc voilà c'est déjà des gens on
doit finir plus haut déjà comptablement
et on a un peu lâché au moins que au
moment qu'on jouait plus rien pour
rappel en septembre dernier l'as Poissy
avait perdu 7 points au classement une
sanction suite à une erreur
administrative par rapport à des
licences de joueurs